so every year these men in suits throw
this pigskin ball around and they hit
each other and they run and I don't know
it's weird I don't understand what's
going on all I know is that in between
those happening is there are these
amazing commercials generally awesome
trailers for movies and this time we got
a great new look at the Avengers and man
do I have to change my pants right now
the world has changed at this point I
doubt I clean would surprise me we are
hopelessly outgunned
[Music]
the trailers for the Avengers have
continuously made me nerd in my pants to
such a degree that I don't even want to
speak about because it's embarrassing
what's really cool about this trailer is
usually when you get a second or a third
trailer they have like a whole bunch of
shots you've seen before and it's like
okay let's get to something we've never
seen before and then towards the end you
get some new things this trailer is
almost entirely new mr. stark captain
it's time
you get this awesome shot of Ironman
like fighting off against this this
array of weaponry in the sky but also as
really cool as we get the very first
shot of everyone together in this city
and I was just saying they're like if
they get this movie right it could be
one of like the coolest most nerdly
awesome moments of my life I still
believe in Heroes
[Music]
but they save the best for last and they
know that we want to see the Hulk they
know that they're keeping the whole kind
of under wraps because they got some
things to show with them and they they
know that we want to see and they're
gonna hide it from us they gave us a
really great look of Hulk we got to see
him high-five a plane basically and I
love the line that comes before that
Avengers it's what we call ourselves
Earth's Mightiest Heroes I think I have
an ami we have a Hulk
[Music]
so that looks magnificent to me that
just looks fantastic I'm so excited for
the Avengers what did you guys think of
the Avengers trailer what'd you guys
think of the Super Bowl who do you want
to win I was rootin for the Giants what
about you guys let me know in the
comments below maybe like this review
you can subscribe to my channel and get
stuck mine eyes
[Music]